(cornemuse)
- Une abbaye presque millénaire.
Depuis 1066, c'est ici qu'ont eu
lieu tous les couronnements
des rois d'Angleterre.
(cornemuse)
Un lieu hautement symbolique
poursasasasasasasasasasasasasast
le règne a été le plus long
deisisistoire britannique.
(chant religieux)
cececercueil est entré,
suivi des arrière-petits-enfants
de la reine. Au cours de
rorororororororororororororororé
une place centrale.
Mais parmi les 2000 invités
dans l'abbaye, otatatatatatatats
d'autres monarchies et des chefs
d'État e e e gouvernement venus
des quatre coins du monde.
Pendant son long règne,
Élisabeth II a vu se succéder
15 premiers ministres
britanniques, 14 présidents
ministres canadiens.
La reine avait déclaré que
sa vie serait consacrée
au service de la nation
et du Commonwealth.
"Jamais une telle promesse
n'a été aussi bien tenue",
a souligné l'archevêque
de Canterbury.
(chant religieux)
Pendant la cérémonie;
des chants religieux et
de la cornmumumumumumumumumumumi
en jouait tous les jours
poursososouveraine.
(cornemuse)
Puis un long hommage
sans bruit.
Deux minutes de silence
qui ont été respectées bien
au-delà de l'abbaye.spspspspspse
vert au coeur de la capitale,
des dizaines de mill
de personnes ont suivi
les funérailles d'État
sur des écrans g
Des Londoniens, mais aussi
partout au pays.
Juliet et Claire, deux soeurs,
se sont retrouvées ici pour
la cérémonie. L'une vient
de Newcastle, l'autre
des heures de déplacements
pour rejoindre ce rassemblem
Sans être une grande
monarchiste, elle affirme avoir
qui a consacré sa vie à servir
le pays.tététététététététététét.
C'est quelqu'un que nous
tenionururur acquis",
lance-t-elle, émue.
(cornemuse)
profité de ce jour férié pour
se recueillir, faire une pause,
sachant bien qu'une fois
le deuil terminé, les enjeux
comme l'inflation et la cris
de nouveau dans l'actualité.
"La vie cs s s s s s s s s s se
à l'Abbaye terminée,
la dépouille d r r reine a
entrepris son dernier voyage
au coeur de la capitale.
Urcrcrcours réglé au quart
de tour avec un passage devant
le palais de Buckingham.
Mais la destination finale est
un autre château, celui
de Windsor, qui pendant
la résidence principale
de la reine.
(chant religieux)
C'est dans cette chapelle
qu'Élisabeth II a été inhumée
sa mère et son père.
Une ultime cérémonie qui
marque officiellement la fin
d'un capapapapapapapapapapapapë,
Radio-Canada, Londres